bonsoir à tous l'heure de votre journal
de l'Afrique soyez et bienvenue à la une
de l'actualité sur le continent un
procès pour l'histoire celui dans des
derniers suspects du génocide des Tutsi
au Rwanda à 87 ans passés Félicien
kabougat est traduit en justice à La
Haye pour son rôle présumé dans le
massacre d'au moins 800000 personnes
les présidents Ghanéens gants bien
dépêchent à Bamako la CEDEAO tente une
nouvelle médiation avec le Mali objectif
faire libérer les 46 soldats ivoiriens
détenus dans le pays depuis le 10
juillet dernier
et puis la suite de notre série
consacrée à l'éducation nous irons ce
soir au Bénin ou des populations nomades
se sédentarisme progressivement ce qui
facilite vous le verrez la scolarisation
des enfants
il ne s'est pas présenté à l'audience de
ce jeudi Félicien kabuka absent à son
procès devant le tribunal pénal
international pour le Rwanda autrefois
riches et puissant il aurait joué un
rôle clé dans le génocide des Tutsi des
hommes des femmes des enfants massacrés
dans les années 90 au Rwanda aujourd'hui
détenus au quartier pénitentiaire des
Nations Unies à la haie au Pays-Bas
Félicien kaboula avait pété non coupable
lors d'une première comparution en 2020
Laurent berthecher
l'ouverture d'un procès historique même
si le principal intéressé manque à
l'appel Félicien kabuka ne s'est pas
présenté au tribunal pénal international
de La Haye mais son absence n'aura pas
empêché la tenue de la première audience
et toi c'est sa décision il n'y a
absolument aucune raison médicale qui
justifie son absence c'est un choix
stratégique de sa part il a le droit de
ne pas se présenter donc le procès a
débuté sans lui
après 25 ans de cavale Félicien kabuka
est arrêté en France en mai 2020 un
tribunal spécialisé lui reproche le
financement de la radio des Mille
Collines qui encourage les massacres de
toutes ci il y avait beaucoup de
messages qui disaient que les outils
sont des
ennemis du pays il faut les tuer c'est
comme ça que beaucoup de néerlandais
beaucoup de extrémistes ont été
convaincus qu'ils doivent quand même à
tuer
pour ses responsabilités au sein du
média extremiste kabuka est jugé pour
incitation à commettre le génocide il
est également accusé d'avoir
personnellement distribué des armes au
milice Hutu son procès est donc suivi de
près par les autorités rwandaises qui
espèrent un dénouement rapide et une
condamnation exemplaire pour le
financier présumé du génocide le temps
passe est donc que les gens vieillissent
il y a des organisateurs qui sont morts
on l'a appris par après 10 ans 15 ans
après et qui n'ont qui ne sont pas
passés devant la justice et ça c'est pas
bien pour l'histoire du pays c'est pas
bien pour les victimes
âgées de 87 ans Félicien Kabuya plaid
non coupable et ses avocats réclament
l'arrêt des poursuites en raison de son
état de santé une demande rejetée par
les juges
à les associations de victimes du
génocide qui pour certaines n'ont pas
fait le déplacement à La Haye le suivent
de très près ce procès depuis le Rwanda
il regrette l'absence de Félicien Kabuga
à l'audience de ce jeudi Clément diros
la preuve de ces crimes ce sont les mots
prononcés par le procureur lors des
déclarations limères du procès de
Félicien Kabuya alors ces mots résonnent
ici à Kigali la capitale ou a vécu
l'accusé après ses 30 ans les
représentants des rescapés qui qui
attendent de nouvelles révélations sur
sa cavale de deux décennies se disait
bien plutôt déçu par le refus de kabuja
d'assister à l'ouverture de son procès
mais il se félicite des mots employés
par l'accusation lors de ce premier jour
pour le procureur Kabuga a joué un rôle
central en incitant à la haine des Tutsi
et en ouvrant la voie au génocide il
affirme entre autres que l'homme
d'affaires a financé et armé les milices
extrémistes responsables des massacres
contre les Tutsis les déclarations
liminaires se poursuivront demain et la
présentation des premières preuves
débutera le 5 octobre au Pays-Bas
sont arrivés au Mali ce jeudi le chef de
l'État togolais à quant à lui dépêcher
son ministre des Affaires étrangères
reçues par le colonel Gotha la
délégation est venu négocier la
libération 46 soldats ivoiriens
interpellé le 10 juillet dernier alors
arrivé dans le pays Bamako a considère
ses hommes comme des mercenaires voulant
à tenter à la sûreté de l'État bonsoir à
vous Serge Daniel merci d'être avec nous
en direct Serge avant de revenir sur
l'enjeu de cette mission est-ce que vous
voulez bien nous rappeler ce que l'on
reproche précisément à ces soldats
ivoiriens
nous sommes le 10 juillet dernier donc
un avion vol spécial arrive de d'Abidjan
à Bamako à son bord à bord de l'avion il
y a 49 militaires qui sont venus
officiellement en soutien aux forces
allemandes de la ministre alors ils sont
interpellés dans un premier temps la
ministre mal la mission de l'ONU au Mali
a dit oui ce sont des gens de
l'administration sont des offres des
soldats qui sont venus en soutien à des
forces de la ministre et puis retro
pédalage la ministrement du nom ce ne
sont pas des membres de la ministrement
nous ne les connaissons pas alors il y a
eu un bruit ils ont été arrêtés et puis
inculper la fête judiciarisée mais en
même temps Bamako a dit ce sont des
militaires mais nous voulons négocier
leur libération avec Abidjan et Bamako a
posé des conditions notamment dit oui à
Abidjan par exemple il y a des
ressortissants maliens recherchés par la
justice il faut qu'on ne les livres et
il faut pas que Abidjan abrite des
opposants alors l'affaire s'est
embrouillée ainsi et puis vous avez
récemment l'ONU a dit ce ne sont pas des
mercenaires et la soutient de la CEDEAO
et l'affaire était comme ça l'a fait
judiciaire judiciaire d'un côté mais
également de l'autre côté Bamako qui dit
nous voulons négocier pour les libérer
et la gente justement Serge a prévenu
qu'elle ne se laisserait pas imposer une
solution ce sont les mots du colonel
Gotha qu'est-ce qu'il faut comprendre
que d'abord le canal historique de
négociation c'est le Togo mais la
délégation des palais de la délégation
de la Cedeao qui est venu à Bamako qui
achève une visite à Bamako il y a pas eu
de communiquer il y a pas eu de
déclaration mais les lits semblent
bouger il faut attendre encore 48 heures
pour voir comment les choses vont se
passer parce qu'il y a eu également
comme vous le savez probablement une
intervention d'un chef religieux de
shérif de la localité malienne de Yoro
c'est très important l'intervention du
président du Togo même s'il n'est pas
venu aujourd'hui c'est lui qui a le
cannabis historique des négociations et
à Bamako on dit que plutôt les livres
pourraient bouger dans les jours qui
arrivent au parle de lundi attendez un
officier m'a dit attendez samedi
attendez dimanche vous allez voir ce qui
pourrait se passer
au prochain jour merci beaucoup Serge
merci pour ces éléments de compréhension
menacé de destitution le président
sud-africain organise sa défense
auditionnée par le Parlement Cyril
ramaposa tente de justifier de se
justifier sur une importante somme
d'argent subtilisée dans sa propriété
privée de l'impôt dans le nord du pays
au moins 600000 dollars les fait
remontent à février 2020 le chef de
l'État n'avait jamais signalé cette
effraction à la police il est
aujourd'hui suspecté de blanchiment
d'argent on l'écoute
une quelconque forme de blanchiment
d'argent j'ai dit et je l'ai dit
publiquement qu'il s'agissait du produit
de la vente de gibier
la ferra été dévoilée par un proche de
Jacob Zumba le rival du président
ramaposa et c'est ce que nous explique
Caroline Dumay depuis le cap
on appelle ça le farm gate le scandale
de la ferme de la ferme de Cyril ramaosa
qui élève au nord du limpo des animaux
sauvages des buffles des antilopes des
sables qu'il revend très cher dans le
reste du monde et bien en février 2020
un cambriolage saint comme ont emporté
la somme de 600000 dollars en cache et
personne n'en a jamais rien su les
Sud-Africains n'ont été prévenus que
deux ans plus tard par un ancien membre
des services secrets un proche de Jacob
Zuma son rival qui a dévoilé l'affaire
et qui attaque Cyril à ma posa en
justice pour blanchiment d'argent ça
fait plusieurs mois qu'on attend que le
chef de l'État se justifie là enfin
répondu aux questions du Parlement il a
assuré que cette somme était
effectivement le produit de la vente
d'animaux sauvages pas du blanchiment
d'argent et il a promis de se plier à
toutes les enquêtes possible pour
beaucoup de Sud-Africains c'est bien que
le chef de l'État rompe enfin son mais
il y a encore beaucoup plus de questions
que de réponses le grand oral de William
Routot il s'est lui aussi présenté
devant le Parlement mais pour y livrer
son premier discours du président du
Kenya et l'une de ces priorités portent
sur la réforme du système fiscal qu'il
souhaite plus équitable aux riches donc
de payer davantage selon lui
en ce mois de rentrée scolaire nous vous
proposons une série de reportages
consacrés à l'éducation cap ce soir sur
le Bénin nos équipes sont allés à la
rencontre des populations nomades si par
le passé leur mode de vie était
difficilement compatible avec l'école
certaines familles sont désormais prêtes
à se sédentariser ce qui facilite leur
accès à un enseignement plus formel
Emmanuel Soji et Rafael Talley se sont
rendus à gourapotal c'est dans le nord
du Bénin voici le reportage
un tout nouveau campement situé au
confins du nord-ouest du Bénin à la
lisière du Togo et du Burkina Faso près
de 3000 familles peuples vivent ici les
autorités administratives les ont
installées loin des champs des
agriculteurs après des conflits fonciers
meurtriers qui ont opposé les éleveurs
et les cultivateurs dans la région de
kogly en 2018
ici c'est mieux si tu obtiens de quoi
manger et boire tu ne trouveras pas de
meilleur endroit changer de lieu de vie
tout le temps ce n'est pas la meilleure
solution la mise à disposition de
centaines d'hectares de pâturage a eu
pour effet la sédentarisation des
familles ce qui a ouvert la voie à
l'alphabétisation l'école est très
importante contrairement à ce que nous
pensions j'ai compris que si nos enfants
des diplômes ils pourront améliorer leur
vie si j'étais à l'école plutôt je
n'aurais pas été en conflit avec les
cultivateurs quand on va à l'école ça
nous est ensuite à mieux comprendre les
lois et il y a un respect mutuel
au deuxième jour de la rentrée des
classes une ONG de la région qui a
ouvert cette école pas comme les autres
dans plusieurs camps a adapté son
programme aux réalités et à la langue du
milieu
ils vont aider leur maman afin de
calculs parce que les mamans n'ont pas
eu la chance d'aller à l'école
l'éducation devient une urgence au
moment où les terres non cultivées se
rarifient et où la démographie explose
on ne peut pas continuer sur cette même
lancée que tout le monde continue de
faire de l'élevage avoir avec beaucoup
d'animaux et ça va continuer par faire
des dégâts ça va continuer avec les
conflits pour l'instant seulement 30%
des enfants du campement fréquentent
l'école le maître est payé grâce aux
cotisations des parents
je suis fière de ma fille Awa car elle
peut me dire ce qu'il y a dans le
téléphone elle compose les numéros et
elle lit les messages aussi
pour autant la sédentarisation des
éleveurs pour une intégration sociale et
économique et loin d'être gagné dans le
nord du Bénin les ONG appuyant ses
communautés ont considérablement réduit
sinon stoppez leurs activités comme la
formation à la culture du forage en
raison de la progression de l'extrémisme
violent insiste à chef votre journal de
l'Afrique on se retrouve pour une
nouvelle édition dans 45 minutes d'ici
là c'est Audrey racine qui vous retrouve
[Musique]
septembre 2002 le Jul aferrier
effectuant la navette entre Dakar et
Ziguinchor en Casamance sombre sous le
poids de ses passagers
n'étaient pas opérationnelles il y avait
qu'un seul moteur au lieu de prendre 450
ou 550 ils ont pris 2000 personnes sur
les 1863 victimes seul 450 corps ont été
repêchés 20 ans après la justice n'a pas
été rendue et les parents de victimes
n'ont pas pu faire leur deuil l'épave
n'a jamais été remontée
de mes enfants il faut que justice soit
faite que les gens soient condamnés
[Musique]
billet retour présenté par Vincent roux
à voir sur France 24 et France 24 com